ça ne faisait que 25 minutes que les
juges de la cour suprême s'était retirée
pour délibérer
mais c'était suffisant pour infliger au
gouvernement harper son troisième revers
devant le plus haut tribunal du pays
dont le dossier omar khadr on béatrice
vaugrante d'amnistié internationale
était là la cour suprême clairement à
donner une décision sans appel je dirais
et sans s'enfarger dans les fleurs du
tapis
cette expression là les juges en chef
déclare que les huit ans de prison
imposée à omar khadr représente une
peine pour adolescents il devrait donc
la purger dans une prison provinciale et
non pas dans un pénitencier fédéral ce
qui lui donnerait accès à davantage de
programmes de réhabilitation et
d'enseignement hôtel jugement peut
sembler théorique puisque omar khadr est
sorti de prison la semaine dernière mais
avec l'appel du gouvernement rappelle de
cette libération
c'est ci pourrait n'être que provisoire
son avocat restent prudents
selon lui le gouvernement a des motifs
personnels contremarques adhèrent les
conservateurs se limite à recycler
dépendent leur réaction la déclaration
indique omar khadr a plaidé coupable à
des crimes odieux y compris l'assassinât
du sergent infirmiers de l'armée
américaine christopher speer
le gouvernement avait publié une phrase
presque identique la semaine dernière
lorsqu'omar khadr a retrouvé la liberté
ça serait le teint qui décrochent parce
que les délais de toute façon il est
sorti - tous que d'aller se gratter la
tête pour se trouver une autre raison
pour pour pour monde démontrer à leur
base qui continue de ces deux d'essayer
de 2
le garder monsieur kader aussi longtemps
que possible la raison rien n'indique
que les conservateurs aient l'intention
d'abandonner leur recours
malgré cette troisième défaite en cour
suprême
le prochain rendez-vous de cette longue
saga judiciaire est prévue en septembre
prochain lorsque le gouvernement tentera
à nouveau de renverser la libération
assorti de conditions d'omar khadr et si
madeleine les morin radio canada ottawa